the quick breakdown here is what 25
seconds until kickoff it is the
one-minute madness warzone rated players
54 currently there is a maximum entry of
what a maximum entry of 150 average
rating 1865 times the handicap ending in
30 minutes
anybody can enter if you are player on
chest cube there is no criteria the
entry fee is fifty cubits but here we go
I'm not set on that let's roll here
okay we already played once we already
played once let's get this thing out of
here Sicilian how much time do I have
how much time do I have
and my mouse is already not treating me
well it's already not treating me well I
only have 40 seconds and they have 40
seconds less than 40 seconds go go and
this guy plays fast this is the one that
should have beaten me he's gonna give me
a beating this time I could feel it I
could definitely feel it a beating is
coming okay wait wait wait wait wait
right here kick this night away what is
my net and g3 doing it's pathetic my
knight on g3 is pathetic I want to stop
Knight to b4 stuff what is he what is my
knight doing let's get it to f3 pawn
push is probably good pawn push is
probably good hopefully it isn't played
hopefully isn't played okay
this side is locked down locked down
let's come over here Knight to f3 let's
take this I don't want to do Knight to
f3 anymore I want to take the knight
there down upon I don't want to take it
though I shouldn't have I shouldn't it
give me the pawn now give me the pawn
now okay I'll take it now
oh that's too taken oh oh I don't have
any time though wait maybe I should have
taken that draw they offered to draw
they offered a draw right there is the
rook gonna move what's my King doing
what's my King doing Queen activity
um what am i doing what am i doing my
opponent wants a draw I want to win
though can I win this can I win this we
got what do we got what do we got
should I be taking this draw um okay I'm
gonna take a draw that was so bad I
guess I had to do that
that was the best-case scenario for me
my opponent was flying okay you know
what it's time for I need to get I need
to go fish and this is gonna sound super
foreign those that are watching in that
hour Starcraft 2 players let's do this
fishing pole this is what I'm getting at
I'm going for fishing poles but it's not
gonna happen in this game get the dark
square Bishop and then get on some dark
squares that's the plan that's the big
plan here dark sphere bishop no I should
deal with the clean ah all right how
much time okay I have actually I could
be coming back actually from this one
maybe one day oh I'm in check I am in
check right here Oh Queen takes Knight
Queen takes Nick don't see Queen takes
oh look we take sand I was there with
the killer Fork their killer is a killer
fork right there I dodged a bullet in
the bullet in the one minute madness I
should say I dodged a bullet
hang on get out of there and then let's
attack the b3 pawn Oh I dodged a bullet
right there
I definitely dodged a bullet once there
could be rook takes here there better
not be let's hit this rook and then
trade Queens rook block I'd give check
and then I get this pawn you might be
pawn push here that might be the best
resistance no back to tournament they
resigned 12 somebodies 12 9 6 4 and
- I got nothing out that first game but
it just did what well when I would that
first game that first game was just I
was just wow how do you how do you say
it all that happened was my clock ran
out and there was less time I didn't get
any points nothing good happened of it I
guess I could have lost I coulda lost
that's what good happened okay
let's launch these ponds launching the
ponds let's do this let's chop that guy
up and then get my Knight to d5 that
Bishop is an animal it's an animal okay
that's probably not a good choice maybe
we'll take the pawn take the pawn queen
h3 killer
okay the bishops close to trapped I
think it might be trapped I think it's
going to be trapped I think it's going
to be trapped or it's gonna be shut out
of the game forever it's shut out the
game forever it's shut out of the game
let's open up the H file open up the H
let's throw a check first and then open
no actually the Queen has to give itself
up oh that's brutal isn't it that's
definitely brutal okay let's just win
this one now let's just win let's go
hear that bishop I was gonna play b3 but
that wouldn't be good
why'd I do that I was stupid okay let's
come over here let's take here why am i
allowing these sneaky moves by my
opponent that why does it have to be so
scary okay let's just pile up on what
pile up I want to trade on some rooks
here actually let me do this
you do this keep them honest here and
look to h3 I want to get to h3 can I
make that happen
there's no me is there oh wait a second
I have to give up my queen how much time
is left oh they could have just taken my
queen that was bad that was bad
technique back to turn them in 30 1714
I'm not going anywhere
windmill windmill 100 is up there with
10 points is vestnik a Sicilian Oh
click resign come on you dropped a piece
you know you want to resign if you drop
a piece job tonight
get development in oh man
I guess that's ok my king I'll be right
over here right trade Queen's trade the
Queen's there we go this is this is safe
now right this is safe ok looking for
tricks checks checks and let me just
come back here f5 they're stopping that
very good that was a good one
right there ok my knight they chased my
knight to a good square I have forks
maybe forks my bishop okay get my rooks
doing something soon there's Bishop
check they resigned back to tournament
thirty twenty seven twenty seventeen
seventeen a lot of time left m'kay m'kay
having four points in the tournament let
me play some gambit here Knight up c3
Bishop to c4 hmm where's my um where's
my advantage
okay okay I'm looking to smash open the
Kings side or they're not on the Kings
side just yet I can get out of the pin
with Queen h4 if there's more pressure
put on my knight on f3 let's see if that
happens is it gonna happen let's do this
let's do that first I got that weakness
in there Bishop back take my knight
what's gonna happen whoa this is scary
this is very scary but now it's not my
queen could come out to defend now if we
come out to defend I thought rook right
there right away
there is checks there's Forks let's get
the Queen's off the board pressure on f2
there is Queen g3 checks maybe in some
lines there is no rook g8 just yet okay
so the Queen's are off
bored get my king out of this G file I
want to keep it closed in fact no why'd
I do that
let's come over here there is no pawn
push there's a check and I could pick it
off okay they missed that and now I want
to just double up on what double up on
why I need to watch over my knight
I think watch over that night okay let's
get out of this actually gonna get out
of this trade rooks it might take here
now that wouldn't be good
just recapture like this 21 seconds how
much time do they have just do that
throw a check-in
maybe there's me soon I was ready to
just move my knight that would be really
bad the rook would get on f2 okay I just
want to make sure that that rook is not
gonna do any damage here no damage
I don't want any damage to be done here
let me just come back this game is not
gonna end we have a time issue more than
anything time is she more than anything
back to tournaments 56 how does somebody
of 56
I guess they probably won their first
game unlike me okay launch that each
pawn launch the H pond opened it up this
is only four bullet chests you don't
want to do that in regular chess hang on
you don't want to drop your Queenie than
regular chess or bullet chess pushing
them Bishop around let's do this and
then the bishop has to back up or is it
backing up let me back up voluntarily
I'm looking to push this okay now now no
no no no no what now what's going on
pressure let's do this there's gonna be
pressure on my punt I want to watch over
it how with my pawn and let's do this
the Knights gonna be playing here I
gotta get out of this soon and the pawns
gonna push the H pawns gonna push or not
let's do this I thought there might be H
for Bishop trying to get on this
diagonal how much time is left I need to
get my king over here I want to get in
c4 next my rope to c8 a Bishop to b4
would be wood nice one day this Knight
is kind of boxed out just because of my
central structure let's go the Knights
looking to repossess
f 3 night right here could induce a lot
of weaknesses H 2 is coming under fire
next or a - excuse me and now with this
pawn push I think I'm not going to push
B 5 just yet chase the Queen away uh-oh
where's the Queen gone the deflection
more deflection bishop here there's
bishop check but then the Queen has to
leave no there's actually just pawn push
no actually it's this never mind
pin the Queen I'm looking for mate next
I'm on the clean recapture with check
this is made actually back to tournament
that was a fairly quick 190 there 53:39
38 19 and changed last warrior
here we go 30 30 Grand Prix Grand Prix
let's go back my bishop up but it does
not move like that let's go here
f4 9 f3 Castle Queen e1 Queen h4 f5 okay
let's go let's go let's go
Queen e1 I still want to follow through
with that take with my bishop or Knight
I'm not sure which ones better clean
right here is very forceful take with my
rook looking for a pawn push here we go
looking for an attack big attack pawn
camp moved the Queen is pinned pawn push
is cut this is killer this is a one game
this is looking for mate the knight has
to block looking to just chase the night
away next this pawn pushes I better
remember to take that clean pawn push
let's do this there's Queen f6 there's
Queen takes pawn queen back over let's
throw a check in actually oh and then I
could take the knight next I'm glad I
saw that one there we go there is a pin
let's give another check where's the
mate is there a mate soon looking for
soon pin the Queen trade Queen's at
least okay now I have an edge on time
and I just want to get rid of that
Knight get rid of that Knight Bishop
here that night needs to go get that
night out of here get out of there
Knight here we go
get rid of the knight okay they missed
that come on resignation you know this
is beat there we go back to tournament
there we go back to tournament we got 17
change 42 110 68 man how do you get 110
points that's a lot of points okay here
we go
I shouldn't have gone with this I
shouldn't go with this setup okay let's
go here and then they're gonna build my
center I get it in d5 let me get in d5
okay here we go
I've been d5 it's a two to zero majority
in the center I could push my opponent's
pieces around maybe let's get out of a
pin h6 there is no Bishop back otherwise
it gets trapped with g5 and now I'm
looking to pinpoint b2 next with my
Bishop and rook but the bishop is
avoiding that exchange watching over the
pawn bishop here pinning the knight get
rid of the Starks are Bishop rook to c8
okay not so fast
I have to watch that not so fast let's
come here oh no no no no let's take that
and then let's come over here hit that
Bishop and then pin the knight or fork
no there is no fork right away because
Knight f5 and then there's an image in
between what my bishop would be hanging
so let's do this and now this is back on
now this is a threat the knight is
pinned what does it do there is no pawn
push I could take with the record the
Queen and now this is free the bishop
you give a check whoa whoa whoa what am
I missing
let me hit the Queen first this is a
little scary definitely a little scary
here I want to make sure that that Queen
is out of here I don't want to deal with
any trouble here I don't want to deal
with any trouble so Queen here let me
just take this I have this defendant
there's no there's not gonna be anything
all right
you hit the clean hit this Queen first
and then push this Knight around or the
bishop where's there a knight where is
there night that light square Bishop is
coming to life here but oh wow I can't
believe I missed that that's all right
though okay they forfeit on time back to
tournament 131 or yeah 130 86 56 56
where we out here um here we go no no no
yes okay e4e for and then okay fantasy
this could maybe oh they're going with
that what is that move
what is that move looking for a quick
mate quick made on H 5 H 5 oh they're
running away their King would just run
away here maybe I still should have done
that oh yeah let's do it now I guess but
ha man I wish I would have wait
Castleman made on f7 they're avoiding it
okay they're avoiding it I'm getting
upset that they're moving yeah I don't
want them to avoid it oh they're giving
me the Queen the Queen is cooked Knight
here could be pre moved mates soon
discover checks discover check and then
looking for mate really soon oh wait
this is leading to mate check and then
check and then mate even if the knight
isn't there okay back to Turner I got
that 172 151 Oh 672 how can I catch that
top guy that's not happening that's
definitely not happening I don't even
know if it would be happening if if what
if I didn't if I drew that um first game
that first game was a dud but um yeah it
did nothing for me even if I won that
game that's what I was trying to say you
know not so few words so break down the
center I'll build the rookies opposite
my queen that is a bit scary it's
definitely a bit scary looking to
conquer that efore point that's why I'm
going with undermining first this d3
pawn if I capture first and then push is
a different story
d takes II D takes EC for does maybe
nothing beyond supporting a point for
one of my pieces on the d3 square what's
going on there clock is don't tell me
something happen my computer
no it's nothing Apple my computer okay
let's chop that up chop this one up and
then get out of pins get out of the pins
move my knight pressure on this point
get my rook on the only open file
ah that's a little bit annoying or a lot
annoying actually I don't want okay this
is a problem I got to take that night
that night can't be tolerated can it
let's try it take my bishop just take my
bishop oh now it's a problem now that's
a big problem night right there is gonna
be good let's do this
I'm not even sure what it's doing I'm
gonna do it though not even sure what
it's doing I'm gonna do it though okay
and then what's that okay I could get
some get some what let's kick this away
and then look for what next we're on the
seventh night right here defends
everything but they don't have any time
no time right okay grab this and then
this I'm on the rook back here Bishop
there if the knight moves the discovered
stuff on the rook Bishop check check
push back determent they're down on time
170 125 91 7125 90 here we go here we go
Oh more okay fantasy just take okay now
maybe there could be big problems okay
we might see a fishing pole or something
like it something like it very soon
fishing pole land castle castle castle
might still be there
it's still there it's still there I
think I think it's still there check
discover check or now we got may coming
up is it still there mate it's right
sune g3o
let's chase that rook away first I could
have done this as well my bishops
watching over this pond okay this is
still good this is still good oh they
dropped that come on what are they doing
making to threat making one threat
unavoidable unavoidable back to
tournament poof 19145 110 19145 110 a
little less than 11 minutes to go
a little less
at 11 come on let's go let's go let's go
okay windmill again again let's go with
this and Queen c7 or not let's see okay
yes it's in there okay
are we gonna be seeing it here we go 94
it's not happening is it how do you
defend how do you defend against h2 they
didn't defend against h2 okay looking
for MIT I want to get my queen I want to
get my queen where take the bishop
yes it's leading to me to making one the
rook has to block back to tournament
quick quick quick quick quick
come on yes back to tournament 130 19145
130 185 M care m Cara come on pair me up
what's going on here let's go efore
efore d4 more gambits more gambits
scotch gambit they're gonna take bishop
I should've done Bishop to c4
immediately Oh light-square weakness I'm
on the bishop and threatening mate the
Queen has to block they missed me that's
like as close to a scholars back to
tournament that was a quick one to 10
150 I'm in second at second can I catch
that guy I'm gonna try my best I'm gonna
try my best
take him down I'm gonna try and chip
away at that score okay this is not
gonna be a wild game but hopefully I
could still win quickly somehow quickly
could I win okay Knight takes if the
Queen takes okay I'm on c2 Queen here
we'll be losing on the knight build my
son in built my son I like to keep my
queen around here this is a giant pawn
center and RUP to be what okay now this
is a tsunami of pawns coming up here a
tsunami of pawns here let's get them all
going a light squares would be nice
coordinated well with my dark square
bishop okay let's take this out first
and do what next let's get my king here
there is a night check but the night is
close to being trapped maybe it's close
to being trapped let's go here rook
could hit the night let's get this pawn
up to c4 and then b2 becomes a target
and the night becomes a bit stranded in
fact it's close to stranded right now
there are no Knight moves with check I
can move my king up let's do this and
then the knight is actually stuck
that's a stuck Knight right there so
there's gonna be rook a to needed
because I'm gonna put pressure on c3 the
knight is hit oh there is no rope takes
bishop because it leads to me maybe
they'll do it they're not doing I could
defend my bishop with pawn push even
though it's there's a pin can be hit
again
let's move my king up King activity pawn
push I should have done pawn push that's
the most direct thing here we go the
Knights out of play and I'm able to
clean what do we got
come on you know this is beat you know
this is beat I could have taken the
night it's okay now I could take here
back - tournament 170 oh I'm in 3rd I'm
in 3rd - 10 185 m'kay m'kay how much
time was left maybe like I don't know I
should've just taken that pun okay now
now I'm gonna push my opponents pieces
oh come on resign are you gonna resign
click did my castle and that's losing I
don't want to open up that age file for
them so let's oh okay they didn't do
that I'll take the light-square bishop
down and then this pawn okay there's
checks the knight can block and let's
just go here the night is still pinned
Queen to f3 just take with my queen
Castle castle Queen side I think and
then look for a 5v5 is on I could take
like okay let's do a 5 right now is that
Knight gonna move
gonna move isn't it let's go here f2 is
gonna fall but I want to just break up
their Center oh I shouldn't have done
that
this is scary oh okay they didn't they
didn't run with that there was rook
takes f2 right there there is no pawn
takes Knight because I'm on the Queen
there's no pawn takes Knight let's get
rid of that before it plays here get
over here Bishop to f3 f3 and then pin
point c6 is the plan
c6 I want to put it under fire now it
gets there with tempo okay with check I
want my Queen where
oh I'm on the Brooke it'd be nice if I
realize I'm on the rook for forever um
okay let's get this in looking for me on
the back rank that's close
oh my goodness why did I miss that I
could have taken their Queen how much
time I only have 11 seconds I'm in a pin
oh man let's go let's go let's go trade
that was so ridiculous trade queens
please let's just trade Queens come on
trade Queens okay we trade Queens now
let's get no that's a mouse lip let's
get this pun and then get this one going
go go go go go stepladder get this pawn
first come on over here
what do we got what do we got what do we
got they're down on time back to
chairman forever forever here we go here
we go take on d4 or not no we're gonna
have this g6 Bishop g7 Knight f6 we're
working with this structure close center
look for play on the wings if the center
is closed
'if I've looking to have 'if I've under
my control very soon hopefully hopefully
very soon be fought this was to prevent
Knight to be 5 I want to get Knight to
g4 Knight to g4 I think I'm better now
Knight here d5 is under my control I
think I have a good spot right now I'm
in a good spot I have a good spot I'm in
a good spot take with the bishop if
captures otherwise there's a pin against
my what what am I trying to say the
otherwise would be a pin along this
e-file okay Bishop takes Knight come on
what do we have oh this is with the
check they missed that are they gonna
resign come on resign check Queen here
no matter what there might have been
Bishop here for something let's do this
now it's there something like it's
leading to mate isn't it it's definitely
think that is mate back to tournament
272 35 to 10 less than 4 minutes left
less than 4 can I get um another win or
two o light squares f7 f7
f7 f7 I'm looking for f7 I'm still
looking for f7 I'm still looking for f7
is it gonna happen I'm still looking for
7 although I'm also looking for a wife
work that would be nice that would have
been nice
that Knight needs to go and stupid that
was stupid
what am i doing I have to go into
defensive mode man this is not working
out this is not working out here okay
now I'm getting chased around not cool
now cool it out Queen g4 if Knight to h5
oh oh oh okay this is killer threat
making one I'm on this I'm not a lot of
things and a lot of things Knight each
five I get the rook at the very least f7
that's what I was talking about earlier
I was talking about earlier but I
couldn't anticipated that happening
Forks tricky Forks tricky Forks the
Queen is hit I'm just looking for f7
maybe still can you believe it f7 h7
Queen g6 Queen g6
killed the night go to h7 I don't know
if that really works right away let me
double up I don't know if it works right
away maybe I pushed my H pawn push my H
pawn he wants to play that H prime wants
to play let's take here 18 seconds let's
take this guy they're just throwing some
pieces at me I'll take that one too pawn
push oh they could throw an in-between
check the knight has to move though
main threat though as soon as I take
tonight now they have this pond it's
made the night moved back to tournament
292 fifty five to thirty to ninety to
fifty five to thirty what do we have how
much time is left let me take a peek two
minutes and change is gonna be the last
game maybe I can get a third place could
I get a third can I get a third I'm
gonna try I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try here we go here we go here
we go here we go pin no I should have
pinned the night no Castle kingside
Castle kingside come on okay they're not
they're happy some sack against b5 let's
do this and then support my knight get
Knight to d7 Bishop to beef seven I
shouldn't have done that that was stupid
I was stupid that was a dummy that was a
dummy move right there
I shouldn't open up that file I'm on
this twice I'm on the clean what do we
have 36 seconds to do something quick
stay on this diagonal looking for this
point looking for this point it's under
fire next take the knight I can
recapture like this and I'm on this
point right here do I take with my
bishop I like going with that and then
our do I should I've done that let's do
this get my knight here soon I want to
watch out for this get out of this pin
no oh no I didn't have me the bishop is
there to watch over it okay I got a
capture like this block
I'm gonna take my rook and then I get my
Queen to c4 Queen a c4 hits the bishop
threatening mate mate threat the Queen s
to block how's the Queen gonna block
back to tournament when we got to 50 to
75 42 seconds 42 seconds when we have
290 275 250 how much time oh can I get a
fishing pole fishing pool tactic come on
fishing pole save the day here there's
no fishing pole but there's a piece here
there's a piece maybe they'll resign are
they gonna resign come on you down a
piece wait it says maybe there's still
something over here
keep that night away take the night and
then press f4 nope let's just take the
night
maybe this position could close up a bit
I want to get my knight to f6 f6 and
also f4 open this up how much time is
left very little time very little time
they're gonna play F's they're gonna
move the ref pawn back to turn no it's
not back to terminate its third third
place confetti Oh
third place confetti oh man that was
tough man that first game was a draw
good games all 310 273 250 and then well
yeah okay it was pretty tight up there
okay